Imagínense una planta
que, como todas las plantas,
capta energía del sol durante el día.
Pero a la noche, ilumina.
Imagínense un banco de sangre
para transfusiones de emergencia,
pero de sangre artificial.
Y que de chapa no contagia enfermedades.
Imagínense un organismo
capaz de capturar el dióxido de carbono,
el del efecto invernadero,
sacándolo de la atmósfera.
Pero no solo eso, sino que además
lo convierte en una forma útil de energía.
No sueñen más.
Bienvenidos a la biología sintética.
La mayoría de ustedes seguramente
no oyó hablar de biología sintética.
Pero la van a oír en los próximos años.
Biología es el estudio de la vida.
Y sintética no viene
del "breve" o "resumido",
sino de artificial,
que no está en la naturaleza.
Los biólogos sintéticos,
diseñamos organismos
para que nos ayuden a hacer algo.
Puede ser algo abstracto,
como estudiar la vida.
O palpable, urgente,
como tratar una enfermedad,
generar energía limpia
o detectar un contaminante.
Lo novedoso es cómo modificamos
o generamos nuevos organismos vivos.
Y eso lo hacemos mediante el uso,
el diseño y la combinación
de bloques biológicos.
Son biobloques como Rasti,
Lego o Mis ladrillos.
Y cada biobloque representa una función.
Podemos diseñar un biobloque
que, al ponerlo en una célula
genere el color rojo,
que genere olor a banana
o que genere hemoglobina,
la de la sangre.
Todos los biobloques están hechos de ADN,
que es el material en que se guarda
la información genética.
Y son fáciles de combinar unos con otros.
Entonces, un investigador
hace diez, cien, diez mil biobloques,
y los comparte con la comunidad.
Y cada usuario los toma
y los usa para hacer su propio organismo
con la función que desea.
Pero no solo los usa,
también los modifica,
los combina, les da otros usos.
Puede crear.
Y lo más maravilloso
para quienes nos apasiona
la complejidad de la biología
es que funciona.
Okey, tenemos una bolsa llena de funciones
encerradas en biobloques,
¿y qué hacemos?
¡Jugamos!
Armamos, desarmamos,
ponemos, sacamos, reciclamos.
La evolución recicla.
Lo biólogos sintéticos venimos
a ser recicladores seriales
que reutilizamos y combinamos
bloques biológicos
para hacer organismos
con funciones a medida.
Esto puede generar un poco de miedo.
Entonces, ¿cada uno hace lo que quiere?
¡No! Hay muchos controles.
Por ejemplo, las empresas que fabrican ADN
tienen bloqueada la posibilidad
de fabricar toxinas o patógenos,
para que no se hagan armas biológicas.
Y también los laboratorios
que trabajan en biología sintética,
suelen abrir sus proyectos a la sociedad.
En mi laboratorio nos visitan
diseñadores industriales,
artistas plásticos, sociólogos
y exploramos con ellos
esto de la biología sintética.
El fuego quema.
El agua ahoga. Pero no por eso
dejamos de usarlos.
Es solo cuestión de hacer
un uso responsable y seguro.
Okey, pero ¿de qué hablamos
cuando hablamos de organismos?
A los seres humanos
nos gustan las mascotas.
A algunos nos gustan los perros,
a otros los gatos o los potus.
A los biólogos sintéticos nos gustan
las bacterias y las levaduras.
Que son microscópicas
y tenemos muchas, muchísimas.
En la antigüedad domesticábamos
microorganismos
para ayudarnos a producir alimentos.
Como el pan, el yogur, la cerveza.
Hoy también los usamos
para fabricar remedios,
para producir energía,
para estudiar la vida.
Pero no son todos los usos posibles.
También podríamos usarlos
para ser más saludables,
para vivir mejor.
Por ejemplo, podríamos modificar
algunos de los organismos
que viven adentro nuestro.
Sí, tenemos bacterias
viviendo adentro nuestro.
De hecho, un ser humano sano,
tiene unas diez veces más bacterias
adentro suyo que células humanas.
¿A quién se le hubiese ocurrido
hace unos años
el tomar una bacteria
para curarse de algo?
Hoy estamos aprendiendo
a entender esas comunidades de microbios
que viven adentro nuestro
y a cómo usarlos para vivir mejor.
Les quiero contar mi historia
con la biología sintética.
La primera vez que escuché
biología sintética,
pensé que estos son unos chantas.
Inventan un nombre para conseguir
plata o hacerse los interesantes.
Pero cuando entendí de qué se trataba
me deslumbró.
Si con la biotecnología vieja
podíamos recortar palabras
de un organismo y pegarlas en otro
de una forma artesanal y laboriosa,
con la biología sintética
podemos escribir, rescribir
y editar un libro entero.
Tenemos todo el diccionario
o, más bien, toda una biblioteca
en la computadora.
Y podemos combinar
las palabras a voluntad.
Uno de los grandes hitos
de la biología sintética,
fue la fabricación
del primer genoma artificial.
Muchos sabrán que la información genética
está en el genoma y que se puede
fabricar ADN en el laboratorio.
Hace cuatro años, en un laboratorio,
fabricaron, a partir de cuatro botellas
de componentes químicos
un genoma completo.
Después lo introdujeron
dentro de una bacteria
transformándola en una nueva especie.
Es como cambiar el disco rígido
a una computadora
y ponerle otro sistema operativo.
Flor de herramienta.
Y no hay que ser
un supergenio para usarla.
La mayoría de los proyectos
de biología sintética
están motorizados por estudiantes.
De su entusiasmo y su ingenuidad surgen
proyectos impresionantes.
En el 2013, con un grupo de estudiantes
de la Universidad de Buenos Aires,
decidimos estudiar un problema
que le doliera a la sociedad
y que pudiéramos abordar
con herramientas de biología sintética.
Nos decidimos por el problema gravísimo
del acceso al agua potable.
Cerca de cuatro millones de argentinos
consumen diariamente agua
contaminada con arsénico,
principalmente los que toman
agua de pozo, y no lo saben.
O quien sí lo sabe no tiene
una forma fácil de medirlo.
Nos propusimos entonces
diseñar un kit de fácil uso,
tipo un test de embarazo,
que le permita al usuario
saber si el agua de su pozo
tiene arsénico o no.
¿Se acuerdan de los biobloques?
Bueno, combinamos
la función detectar arsénico
con la función generar color.
Los juntamos, los pusimos
adentro de una bacteria
y la transformamos
en un sensor de arsénico, un biosensor.
Este proyecto lo hicimos
en el contexto de una competencia
internacional de biología sintética
donde nuestro equipo ganó
una medalla de oro
y el premio al mejor modelo teórico.
Pero no nos quedamos solo en el modelo.
Tomamos muestras de campo,
reales, y funcionó.
El paso siguiente es generar una carcasa
que permita contener esas bacterias
y poder distribuir este dispositivo.
Este es el prototipo actual.
Uno pone unas gotas
de agua en un pocillo...
(Aplausos)
(Fin de aplausos)
Uno pone unas gotas de agua
en un pocillo, espera unas horas,
y compara el color
que desarrolla ese pocillo
con otros colores de referencia
y así sabe cuánto arsénico tiene su pozo.
Me gusta verlo como un modelo inspirador.
Cuando uno no sabe que algo no
se puede hacer, lo intenta.
Pero cuando sabe que se puede,
se anima a más.
Hoy en día hay empresas
usando biología sintética,
para fabricar esencia de vainilla.
Usando biología sintética para fabricar
un remedio contra la malaria.
O hasta para fabricar tela de araña.
Hoy en día podemos diseñar organismos
que nos ayuden a resolver problemas.
Es solo cuestión de imaginar.
Imaginar un organismo
que nos ayude a cuidar el ambiente.
Imaginar un organismo que nos ayude
a estar más saludables.
a generar energía limpia.
Porque ya sabemos, en biología sintética,
imaginar es poder.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)